[Musique]
là
tu es mort quitte à tout faire
je sais bien à tous elle encore
jouer
je suis
tha
tout ça pour nous détruire
m ouvert je me tâte encore du salon
t
hu
regarde encore encore encore encore
encore encore encore encore encore
encore au cas où mon coeur aux gars car
aucun regard pour de la poule à
m
non
il a tout ce qu'il faut là donc non
parfait avec ladite a été parfait avec
la guitare présent le micro devant un
robert johnson a suffi pour voir
exactement bon son pascal
moi je suis là pour moi je suis là pour
faire les mauvaises critiques
face comme les artistes apportent de
bois c'est toujours bien sûr ben oui
c'est le premier truc que je veux enfin
le jeu à tous je veux dire c'est champ
de gueule pas un des morceaux les plus
bas
depuis
quatre jours
qui sont là là dans ma tête je suis sûr
et ça ne fait rien car toi aussi tu
casses le miroir c'est tous les jours
dimanches matins je me rase athlètes
j'allume des bouger car aujourd'hui j'ai
trouvé
m
et
[Musique]
je suis heureux car aujourd'hui je sauve
ma tête je ne suis pas triste
ou bien peut-être suis-je à blâmer parce
que je
moi je m'en tape
j'aimerai te voir jeu murray
tenteront comprenne je veux faire
l'amour
situent le veut car aujourd'hui je me
sens bien
et
hier
je ne
m
j
[Musique]
j'ai tout vu
et
mais
le problème du rock et ses distributeurs
de finexs de problèmes du rock et c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'ils ont à moindre
dans les autres domaines musicaux c'est
que les anglo saxons se foutent du sens
ils veulent que ça sonne et que quand
nirvana ferry love you machin tout le
monde crie au génie maintenant quand il
fait je t'aime je te tuer en français ça
donne de la mer
[Musique]
tu l'as par un fil du temps je la vis
ça
ça bouge ça va je m'en fous devant la
vie s'écrit
[Musique]
c'est la vie 10 26 hockey league ça
finalement
[Musique]
à quel jeu
à
[Musique]
m
car là
mais
ah ouais
voilà
[Applaudissements]
bah
m
[Musique]
guaino
m
oh
[Musique]
à verdun
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
ce qu'il advient je vais te dire c'est
le regard à travers la mèche
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux